all right corrine
hi mark hi karine
karen tell me where you grew up where
are you from
um i was born on long island new york
riverhead
out very tip of the island
before you get to montauk i guess
and tell me about your your family your
childhood
um
i
my mom
followed my grandparents to florida when
i was just a baby
she remarried and
um i actually didn't know
that my stepdad
he adopted me when they were married and
so i actually didn't know that he wasn't
really my father until 12 i kind of i
actually figured it out on my own um
but i mean it wasn't like i i didn't
care it wasn't a big deal i was like you
know i did
yeah yeah i mean he he's a great
dad yeah so
um
but yeah i grew up in a
you know mom and dad
suburban how do you describe your
childhood um i was a very
anxious child
um i was very shy and
very um
i would i think i just had a lot of
anxiety um
which
started a very young age and um
[Music]
i think my mom just didn't
she didn't understand how
to that maybe that was
something that needed to be
you know
helped she just kind of was like why are
you like this and it's you know can't
why can't you be like other kids and i
do i'm a child i'm not trying to be
anxious it's just that my you know i
don't know how else to be
so
um
so it was a little hard um
because i don't
think that
even though there was a lot
of uh
like my grandmother had a lot of issues
um
with mental
um
and like i think she was a very anxious
person too um
were you an only child i am an only
child yes
um
and uh so
you know it was just a little
rough because
i
always felt that my mom didn't
understand exactly
what was going on and i know
i think i you know
she always she was very
i don't know like now you would call
them a helicopter mom i guess she was
like an extreme helicopter mom
um knew everything that i was doing all
the time um
and
you know it's
there were times when
i guess you know i was going through you
know 12 and 13 and you're like you know
starting like
your hormones and you just don't know or
just like starting to go in like a
little bit crazy maybe i don't know i
just there were times when i know i
probably wasn't the easiest kid um
but
my mom really just
i i mean i love her and i forgive her
but you know she um
she did the best that she could
how she thought she she could and she
she does love me and um
you know i love her
but it was
it was very hard
we had a very difficult relationship um
uh
which
manifested into
me
eventually after college
leaving
tampa florida which is where she lives
still
and um
[Music]
i haven't seen her in 25 years oh really
so
we talk though
um
[Music]
not as much i use
since the pandemic
i used to kind of have a habit of
calling her on my way to work
and
we would chat
but when
the covet hit i just you know my
schedule it got it just got weird
because i was at home all the time and
i
was working remotely and so
it we weren't in that like same
habit of talking all the time every day
but we still but we talk um
you know we have very very differing
views
pretty much everything
and um
you know so i
i think still to this day i'm like
always looking for her approval
um
i think she
you know she she always says like why
didn't you you could have done this or
you could have done that you could have
been a doctor you could have been a
lawyer
why why don't you become a cpa
you know and it
it's like i don't know why she can't
just be proud of me for what i've have
done and accomplished you know
instead of
wishing
you know and because that that's
just not what i wanted
what kind of jobs have you have you done
um
so i have
i
went to college for architecture but i
switched to fine arts so i
graduated with a bfa
um
i did not know what i was going to do at
all
with that
um
and so i went back home after school and
i ended up
working
part-time
as an assistant like an executive
assistant for a general manager for a
chain of optical stores
and eventually their bookkeeper retired
so i became a bookkeeper
which i
still do to this day
um
and
although i have had other
creative jobs i always have fallen back
on bookkeeping as my main gig you're
very into art and fashion i am um and
music
yeah i was a drummer in some bands
um
some like punk and indie bands when i
was younger
um
i
really am into art fashion is my main
i guess obsession i
did have my own
jewel when i
start something i just
go in and like i'm obsessed so i
for when for a long time i was making
jewelry at home and i was just like
amassing a huge amount of handmade
jewelry and
i started wearing it and people were
asking me like oh can i buy that you
know can you make me something
so eventually i was like i guess i can
try to sell
things you know so i was selling jewelry
here in new york at a few stores
but eventually they
had to close down due to economy issues
um
so that was my creative outlet
for for quite a while just making
jewelry
um
[Music]
but
i kind of gave that up too
and focused
on
i guess
collecting fashion
if we want to say yeah is it is it
collecting or is it or is it becoming a
compulsive it's a compulsive-ish problem
i think um you know i
i know we were talking before about
love and i think that
um
feel like i'm trying to
that's what it does it gives me that
like rush of
ah like you know
when i
find something that i really love and
i buy it and then it comes in the mail
and then you open it up and it's this
like
present to yourself you know and then
you get this feeling of like
wow this is so nice you know like i'm so
happy and but
it only lasts for so long you know seems
like
similar to
the feeling of love
yeah
yeah it does
have you been married no
never married no kids no kids no kids
no so your shopping addiction let's call
it you
how dis can you describe it
yeah i mean
it
on one hand it almost feels
like
i feel like i would think people are
going to be like wow
what is her problem she has money to buy
like
great clothes you know like amazing
clothes that she likes like why
why does she have a problem like that's
not a problem but
you know um
it can become a problem
um
i
i start off you know thinking i as
myself as a collector you know collector
of these beautiful objects and then i
get to wear them tell me about the items
you're wearing right now
um
so i have a few designers that i
really love uh vivian westwood being one
of my favorites so i am wearing
a lot of vintage movie in westwood at
the moment my shoes
my pants
my shirt
um
and these are like collectible items
these aren't just yes yes
yes
like vintage collectibles yes yeah yeah
um your cape
uh this is rick owens
um i have my bag is come to garcon which
is another one of my favorite designers
your shopping addiction intense
you're
selecting
the higher higher price items the more
more unique ones
yes from designers yes yes i have i tend
toward the more
out of the box i would say
kind of fashion
um
and is your closet insane
it's a yes it is insane um
i had to install closets
because there were none in my apartment
at all
um except for one and i had to install
closets all the way around my room
[Music]
and they're
completely
jam-packed
full of clothes and shoes designer and
jewelry
yes
yes how much of it do you never wear
so that's what's so hard is because
i forget that there's things in there um
it's hard to even
open like
find things
[Music]
it's hard to
i don't know
it starts to feel like
you have a weight on you
um
and
[Music]
i mean even though these are things that
i
i love um
they start to
own you in a way um
it's hard because i get really fixated
on something and i'll
i'll want it and i'll find it and i'll
buy it
and
you know through the pandemic i've been
working remotely so it's not
that i go out like often
so i feel like why am i why am i doing
it but i still do it i still do it i
can't help it i can't help myself
his technology and the ability to shop
online rather than going to stores
changing the way your
compulsion
yes definitely um
you know
i've been here in new york city for
almost 20
years it's changed a lot
[Music]
every you know there were places that
i would shop here
but they've all they're all gone
so
i turned online shopping and
and i think that's when things just
exploded
um because
it was like
when i found
certain websites that i i
particularly use
um
there's just so much that i could find
that i liked and
you know it's
like i said it's almost like
you will you
you're waiting and you get this
it's like a present yeah
like i said earlier it's like
giving yourself a present and um
it's just uh i don't really know how to
it's hard though because you you know
you get sometimes you get the guilt
shoppers guilt
where it's like why did i buy that i
don't i don't need that um
or
you just you're addicted to the feeling
that you get when
something comes in the mail and you've
that you've been waiting for and it
finally comes
and you open the box and you're
ah
you know but then
that only lasts for so long
and you do it again
and you do it again
and for me
because i get so like fixated sometimes
on just
something and i have to like
look for it and find it and
you know and then
i just i get obsessed and i'll buy it by
everything i can you know because
like i love it like
can't help it it's vivian you know
how much of your weekly paycheck will
you spend on
on items
so i've really
i have tried
to
uh
because although i make a
a great living um i
you know i
i was like still using my credit card
and
i finally
was like i can't do that anymore and i
so now i only buy with
the money that i make um
[Music]
i would say
i mean it depends
it depends on
on the month oh you know but um
i guess
maybe
50 of it
you've been in love before
i don't think so
i thought so
you think maybe this but i don't think
so you don't think so
do you think this is maybe
something yeah a replacement for that
okay
yeah i just it's hard because it feels
like
like i said it feels like a
like people are gonna be like
that is not a problem
why are you you know like
i don't know
and that's maybe that's just how i feel
like that people are going to feel
that way like
there's this girl like
you have a buying all this like high-end
fashion and thinking like that she's
got a problem you know well you i mean
it's not like you have an opiate
addiction
no or a gambling problem where you're
just throwing your money away
yeah
you're doing something that makes you
happy
do you think this is has this replaced
another addiction or any other
addictions you've had in the past
um
[Music]
yeah i think
you know
my mom
i think it all started
i don't know if it started that way you
know when i was a kid and
i was really
early 80s and i was really into like you
know new wave punk rock and you know
stuff like that and
i was
i you know my mom
kind of although she
hated everything seemed to hate
everything about
what you know i liked um
her way of kind of appeasing me in
certain situations she always bought me
things that i wanted um
and i think
you know i'm still searching for her
approval so
maybe you know
i moved from
in my earlier life
you know experimenting with other
like maybe with substances and
that's a long time ago
um
[Music]
and then
that's
that didn't do anything
you know that wasn't
so i think
that it transitioned into
this
because i
was really
i think i'm still searching
for love or
to love myself
um i think we all are
yeah
that is you
yeah
or to get approval
still and
it beats alcohol
yeah i guess yeah
i just
worry
that
it could get
to a point where it's too much um
collecting is one thing but
i don't want it to pass the line into
becoming
a hoarder
although
i don't have the tendencies of not being
able to throw something away or
anything like that or
or give something away i think hoarders
probably
just have everything including junk all
over yeah
that's not me you sound like you're
collecting higher higher end items yeah
yeah but eventually
where do you put them when you live in a
one bedroom in new york city right you
know
if i
if i had a house and i could build a
like
a huge closet
you know in a room
and had my you know everything it would
it wouldn't seem like anything you know
no one would think a second thing but
does the fact that you don't have that
much closet space left slow down your
your spending
um yeah it has it has if you had two
giant walk-in closets you'd probably be
in trouble
no because i could fill them already
so um
yeah
i think i could probably already fill
them
what were your best memories
in your life
my grandparents
um
they lived
in ruskin florida on the little manatee
river
they had
a few acres of land there
and the river was literally like in
their backyard
um
and
i mean my favorite memories are
of being there
um my grandfather had a huge garden
and
he was amazing with plants and things
like that um
and i would go there and i would
you know take my little net and i would
catch butterflies and insects and put
them in little you know
the little containers that you could
look at them and and then i'd let them
go and
i would go down to the river and i would
scoop up fish and fill the little
aquarium in the garage and
and then the next day i would let them
go
and
there was just like so much space and
i like
i could roll or skate around where they
had paved for the driveway because it
was a big like huge round
area sounds wonderful
yeah
it was
um found a lot of
native american artifacts on the
property
um
[Music]
which my grandfather donated
to the museum
in the area
but it was just such a lovely
lovely spot
and sometimes manatees would come in so
it was just
yeah that's my favorite those are my
favorite brains of being there they
sound great yeah
and what's been the roughest part of
your life
oh
i think
probably high school
um
actually
before that
i would say like
fifth to
maybe eighth grade ninth grade
i dealt with some bullying
um
which
because i
was already like
kind of a very timid and
um
anxious person
you know it was just really
back then it wasn't like it is now it
wasn't
talked about
and of course it wasn't online
you know i'm gonna
because i didn't have
when i was an eighth grader you still
had a phone that was connected to the
wall
so
you know um
it was it was just a lot of
stress
and
and that was very
i didn't understand yeah bullying can be
very destructive i didn't understand why
i had a male bully and a female bully so
i just didn't understand
[Music]
why they hated me so much you know i
i never did anything to anybody so
that was just really hard and uh
that's probably the worst times
it's horrible
do you have friends
no
um
no
not really
um
i do have
i still
have
the friend that
um
[Music]
i went to college with and charleston
he's still my friend um
but i kind of isola i have a tendency to
isolate myself
i don't
know how to maintain friendships i think
um
sometimes i just
i think because when i was younger i
wasn't able to
i didn't know
how to keep a friendship because of my
i was never really
allowed like had friends over much like
that anything like that so
i don't know i never
it kind of
right now i
and when the pandemic hit i just kind of
permitted myself away
and
i lost touch with a lot of people
and
so right now i would i would say not
really
no i'll go through phases where i'm i'm
very social
but then i will go through phases where
i just isolate and
you know i go to work and i come home
and that's me you know i have and i
don't
go out i don't do anything and you know
it's crazy it's like you're in new york
the big you know the biggest city in the
country like you know why wouldn't you
go out and
but you know there's times where i would
i would just hermit myself away and um
you know it's sad and that's when i'm
you know friendships fall away and
so when covet hit
that's
it that triggered that
that in me again because i couldn't go
anywhere i was stuck at home
working from home
couldn't go out to
you know my job every day and
couldn't do anything for a while so
i started him like shopping like crazy
and that's when it really like boomed it
was just like
over the last couple years it probably
got a lot worse
no no you know
but you've had romantic relationships
you've had boyfriends i have yeah
i've had
i had um
my first real like i
i had boyfriends
i really didn't have a boyfriend until
college um
and
um
you know
he was actually a really nice guy and
but you know after college he was a year
behind me and i just kind of was like
you know okay see you later you know
i don't know um
you know and then i
i met someone else when i
moved back after college to tampa and
you know we were together for a while he
actually he proposed to me
and um
but it you know it was just another like
falling you know like i don't know it
was like
he couldn't keep his job
you know he was in a band that was
actually
pretty like popular at the time like
in the indie circle i would say like
and so like recording albums with like
actually you know producers and things
and um
yeah you know things just like
went haywire and that just threw me into
a tailspin i had pretty much a nervous
breakdown
at the age of like 25.
i had to
i didn't know what was wrong with me i
was actually up here visiting my friend
i came up to see a friend in philly and
then i came to see
my college friend
he was living here in new york and
i started having panic attacks
and i didn't know what was going on and
they were just constant like
one after the other and i i i didn't
understand like what was happening
it was the worst feeling and people that
have never had a panic attack
don't understand how
how horrific it actually is
and um
you know i
i called my parents and i said i have to
come home i don't know what's wrong
um
so
i literally
like didn't know what to do except drink
because i was like
that's the only thing that could kind of
calm me down i was literally drunk for
like
two days and i had to get on the plane
and
i asked the woman before you even took
off she could give me a drink
she was like no we have to wait till we
take it
but um yeah i mean i hadn't
i got back to florida i had to move back
in with my parents
um
i couldn't leave the house i was became
agoraphobic i
i was seeing um
[Music]
a neurologist and
a psychiatrist they put me on
medications
i started to get better eventually
and um
then you know
it was kind i found out that my
grandmother had had similar
problem at around the same age
um
and
you know none of these things were
talked about you know so
i really am you know it was kind of like
my mom just didn't know like what's
wrong with you just like you know like
do it you know do it like just get up go
outside get
you know like what's wrong
and i just couldn't
just couldn't understand
you know that there might be like a
chemical problem or something triggered
have you taken uh
medications for brain chemistry i have
yes are you currently on something no
do you think they help
i am seeing someone
um
and
because of i had some health issues too
and
um
this is something i don't want to really
talk about but um
yeah i you don't have to okay
um
and uh
so
i
i am like
somebody i am speaking to somebody
so i do see someone like um
and they want me to start taking
medications
um
but i keep putting it off like i don't
want to
[Music]
um
i don't know
obviously you know it's depression and
anxiety um
so
is depression and anxiety what you've
dealt with the most in your life yeah
emotionally yeah
i mean i never really thought of myself
as depressed but i think i just always
was so it was just like my baseline you
know
and and then i would get anxiety
um
in there
but um
you know i haven't
i don't i get panic attacks sometimes
but
nothing like you know that that was
just horrible
um
i mean i still have anxiety issues and
um
yeah sometimes i
i know that
i know for a lot of people this time
you know with the pandemic it's been
really hard on people and people
get depressed
um and i think buying
clothing
was something like i said was like a
self love like
trying to
find something
to give me
like happiness for a little while
um
i
think that
it can only you know but it only lasts
for so long so like i said you don't
have to do it over and over and over and
over
which you have
yeah
which i have yes
um
[Music]
so
it's been
it's just it you know i i feel like it's
like
i know we're saying it's not really
you can't you know
i almost feel like you can't equate it
to to being such a bad
thing but it it can be
or at least it can feel that way
um
[Music]
it can feel
like things start
to own you and they
are oppressing you after a while
instead of giving you that feeling
it starts to do the
opposite makes sense
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about
um what do i worry about
i worry about
where
[Music]
i don't know if i want to stay in new
york
um
[Music]
so i feel like it's lost
the essence that i
of the new york that i really liked um
[Music]
because of technology and covid and
things like that
yeah
and just economy issues and a lot of
things have shut down
yeah almost everything that at least
i felt
you know if you
of course the tourist things are all
still here
but if you live here and you
you know
there are
things that become
you know your like special like things
that you like and and when they all
start to disappear
it's just hard
to want to stay
so i worry about that i worry about
where i'm gonna go
if i do leave
or about what i would do with all my
stuff
i mean that's one thing i
moving and it just makes me almost
nauseous because
i don't even want to have to start to
like think about going through my stuff
and
getting rid of things and
packing and stuff like that
i worry about
being alone
[Music]
i worry about i guess yeah i worry about
being alone you know
sure
this
woman with
fabulous clothes
all alone you know i don't wanna
i don't wanna be
that
um
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
that's hard because
i
i don't know that i could have done
anything differently
um
when you're bullied as a kid you can't
really
figure it out at that age what you
should be doing
yeah
for example
it was really hard for me um
you know
i
just
even going to college
and
um
finally you know being
away from
my mom for the first time
um
that was just
i think
i don't know i think maybe if i could do
it all over again i would
have taken more time before going to
college
because i don't think i don't i don't
know if it's right to just immediately
force you know have a kid and go
straight from high school into college
and
really know what you want to do with
your life
you know that's a lot of
a lot of pressure yeah to make big
decisions
yeah at an early age
i think i would have tried to
take some time
[Music]
and
figure out
myself
because i think
i was kind of steered a lot
by my mom in certain directions
and
i think
i and i understand because she wanted
the best for me and
[Music]
i think i didn't understand like
because
there were so you know it was so
different in our ways of thinking i just
didn't
i don't it was just really
hard
time
and i think maybe that's what i would
change
is
taking some time
off
after
a high school to try to figure out my
life and myself because i think
because i
i just went with the flow of what
i was supposed to do i kind of feel like
i miss still i'm looking you know i'm
trying to figure out myself
and
try to love myself
you know
because i think i
i don't know i think sometimes the
clothes
maybe are like an armor too
um
although i don't dress to not be look
seen obviously
i do but um
i don't know it's almost like
[ __ ] you that's what i how i wanna look
you know
and uh
i wish more people
did that
i don't know you know had a style that
you i don't know
no not like me not like you but everyone
has their own yeah style but
yeah i don't know
you know i just um
the lack of style can be shocking
to people who have it when you see it in
others yeah but every i i i mean i
understand i mean you see people just
wearing sweatpants in a
sweatshirt
and flip-flops yeah
it's just hard to
yeah hard to understand sometimes yeah
what would you say corinne is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
you know it's funny because
even though
my mom and i had a lot of
it was very tumultuous relationship
um
[Music]
i know that
there were things that
she was trying to explain to me
i
i think the thing i've learned is
that
you really gotta
give yourself some time um because
you really don't know everything you
think you know
when you're young
so
i think that's the biggest thing i've
learned is that
you really do
find
realize things as you age
that
you know and you're not you're
i don't know that's such a hard question
to answer not as smart as we think we
are yeah
you just that's i feel like that's it
you you know you think you're so smart
and you know everything when you're
a kid and
you want you know
oh i know that i want to do this and
this and
you know
yeah sometimes you do need to listen to
people that are older than you
so you might have something to say
that could benefit you
[Laughter]
all right corrine thank you so much for
sharing your story
thanks mark
you